[Music]
what is up there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back for Jenifer V episode
five today Johnny how are you
veraciously anticipating this Coy how
are you thinking about V and five being
a Roman numeral so this is the ultimate
episode of gen V five I'll do a GW for
you I got goria guys we are going to
watch this right now leave a like on
this video that'd be very much
appreciated also be sure to subscribe
click the notification Bell to get
notified on our reaction for Gen V
Episode 6 is up here on the Chanel and
as always full watch their own copy of
genv available for super sexual Rejects
at our patreon page we also cover
several things exclusively over there
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included I am ready are you ready we're
all ready let's
[Music]
go oh
good what is that I don't trust vague
liquids in in this show going with drool
optimistically where are we you know
remember we
don't I still feel like it's weird that
they have no guilt about their friend a
of saying like there's not a version
that could work I'm just saying there
should be like a hint of like is what
we're doing okay a line of dialogue just
want to acknowledge we know okay so
everyone that was on scene got mind
wiped yeah that makes the most
sense yeah Dusty a llama hey
SLO hey what's up guys oh
yeah oh I just sorry I just thought
is that right on I just
thought right
on hey
hey I'm just gonna yeah sweet dude
dating Jordan it's like a twofer d
we do
it little
smile you happy you did
it all right I'm ready let's go
again what all right what weird thing we
got in store today
what like
[Music]
electroshock
what
I I don't get it I yeah it's like a full
body I'm going to need I'm going to need
a uh breakdown to explain the new rock
stars do a please explain
this I hate the dream this is
real I
think
y amazing do a girl saw it and choke me
on my misery no the family pleased to
puke oh it's going to be huge yeah lucky
she has that modesty tarp there are days
that I am missing like huge gaps in my
memory mine too what what what are you
trying to
remember maybe they just had a really
good party yeah maybe those days just
weren't that
important oh she's back it's smart of
them to fill this in social media wanted
to plop them at a party all
places no The Keg in the foreground for
size no it just keeps getting worse and
worse for her how long have you been
Snogging Jordan I don't even know how to
answer that is a male tighter
than a female Jesus Emma Emma are you
okay oh my
God comp Sam's just out I was out of
line and I'm so sorry do they not
remember him especially after you
stopped me from doing something terrible
but I'm I'm I'm fine and how far back oh
my God they don't remember because it
meant that you got away
from oh no why are you looking at me
like that oh it's me Sam the woods the
the the start us driveing look hey hey
hey hey Sam that's your name they wiped
all that the blood girl I think you're
confused oh this is terrible TV or Tik
Tok or something you don't actually know
us in real
life oh no this is called a parasocial
relationship they made you forget who's
they yeah good question you know there's
a gap in your memory and he's there evil
people at that school people that don't
want you to know about me or the truth
and you can't trust anyone but we can
trust
you she's right I wouldn't trust me
either not after what I did oh this is
intriguing I'm going to make you
remember remember what that you're a
hero a a real one and a real human being
I do nothing but think of
[Music]
you crazy
toes kind of cute though
right did you uh did you black out last
night I don't really think that's any of
your business Marie we all blacked out
and not just a party the the past few
days think about it I blew off my
interview with Haley Miller but I don't
know why oh oh oh no yeah there was a
kid just now he acted like he knew me
and Emma what kid another student Sam
something I I've never seen it unless
you have and forgot how come they
wouldn't wipe Sam's memory and how did
he get away yeah yeah he must have
wriggled out somehow I think I know who
did this Rufus was here last night
Rufus it's all connected EA Sports It's
in the game of course it's him I wonder
if he made her think that she blew up
his rich or if he actually got his blown
up blue is go we talked about you saying
the
word how could you you know how
sensitive job sir YouTube I'm sorry
Richard his name is
Richard I am this close to perfecting
the virus a viable way to control them
for good but if they discover that man
they want to be able to permanent not
only are they psychologically
controlling not now they can permanently
control them in every way how cool
that's like weaponized super soldiers I
know I love it this is what we should be
spending our R&D in America I want the
girl Marie she's the perfect subject
could speed up my timeline she is
special the special but no you're not
the only one interested in Maron she has
a benefactor and because of that she's
strictly off limits this is like the New
Mutants it's very New Mutants all the
subplot of
this luckily no one saw that but us yeah
I was looking for
something what a nice
Lounge they're all so much calmer CU
they don't have the anxiety of the
things that have been building I met him
in intros pych freshman year 3 days
later I woke up at a random bed with a
camera pointed at me oh boy oh my God he
saw I was awake smiled and said make
this weird and I'll wipe you again oh my
god did you tell anybody he had me on
camera
consenting it doesn't matter I don't
even remember it so your body remembers
body keeps the score that's horrible so
I get him coming after me for revenge or
whatever but I go after you guys cuz he
also wants to be number one definitely
must be working for them government yeah
where's Andre oh Rufus whoa he's
going to kill
Rufus
Emma and knew is you oh my God no girl
you were L last night yeah no you got
that big soup
energy big superp BSC baby someone get
her first positive interaction like with
anyone days start that big YouTube
channel becoming full though that's
awesome no this a situation but I just
want to say it doesn't need to be
weird you don't need to say or do
anything cuz that scumbag mind us and we
weren't acting like ourselves
yeah a I hear you
um but God damn it come on Jordan we're
cool no no not cool yeah yeah totally
why are we resetting the clock on this
will they won't they that's what keeps
me in treat into a ship that's all they
got me it's a brand new R there won't
they what's he doing with Jetty let's
find out wait wait wait wait not tell
he's away from Shetty what you're the
one who want to report this piece of
I don't trust her oh I don't know
why but I am sure without memory you're
just left to your instincts I guess oh
hey that's not
suspicious get Kate back here to make
him hit himself in the nuts all day
again Jordan's so good at acting like
Jordan the casting is so like in sync
yeah it's
interchangeable oh it's a mind trick so
maybe he the the D was fake it's not him
shape shifter
venny what the man Rufus gave me 20
bucks to take his shape I don't
know take the clothes too good job I
think you lost them get the out of
here
whoa oh yeah lock down awesome I never
touched Marie you better kill Dane de
Han you hear
me want you to do the rest of us and why
and maybe I'll consider not putting you
to sleep for good
[Music]
you had to know that was a possibility
hey kind of pulling up the line there
dog damn this guy has such a
powerful that is so powerful how do you
defeat that yeah it's like Xavier that's
why he leads the
Xmen guess you broke the top 100 the
rankings I jumped up to 88
a my mom's been like don't get big it's
weird and gross so now I have like 20
voice about doing a giant Cricket show a
happy for Emma kind of Jordan said we're
cool they changed their mind do you like
Jordan do you want to hang out with them
do you want to talk to them do you want
to put your mouth on their mouth and
other body parts I mean come on this
isn't quantum physics oh my God you you
get the best of both worlds he great
I like
them I I like them but why do you like
them though we don't know that part
they've been kind of mean to each other
they feel like it doesn't even like
flirtatious mean just just mean she
Jordan especially has been stopped you
from how you tell people like pry book
pretty messed up things too yep pretty
direct oh clothing Sam that weird kid
he said something about a
drive-in oh is he like crouching out
there wait to isolate this kid even at
least he understood is but man what a
mess this
time you know what you have to do this
is bad Sam I hate television's Jason
Ritter yeah Jason R really son of a you
said you were going to save
me no I'm going to save the the real
Emma not you you're you're not puppets
aren't worth saving are you like
that whoa
go oh no oh this Show's
amazing a puppet fight let's go let's
go wow
[Music]
yes
yes popcorn bullets bullets oh by the
spine finish him POV Muppet
fight oh no owie yeah
yeah somehow it's more graphic most
violent day at Jim Hansen
Studios the brain I have a single dad
with two
da a
yeah D what if that helps his psyche by
turning into stting
people oh yeah
buddy
barehanded damn put all in the shadows
and revealing the aftermath like that is
really cool yeah that is really
cool oh it's like the Happy Time murders
but more fun yes oh man that guy
Predator he said they made us forget I
mean it has to be more than Rufus it has
to be the school Rufus was with shett
what did she want us to forget and
that's why I have to go find Sam we got
to remember what we've forgotten why the
are you scratching your neck like Tyrone
bigam Warden but I have a red balls oh
what a cette respect there's blood
clotted oh injection site it's a good
call it's a good call very good call
that was fast call
Bo
yeah what the is that it's cuz you got
the
vaccine she's got 5G for sure definitely
everything is Kate I I I I can't soow
down sleep together yes this is how it
happens he put trackers inside of us did
that Sam guy come back no I don't know I
don't trust something about how she's
acting I know she's always in her dorm
being like ignore this and I think Dean
Chetty is a part of it do I have one
too yeah I was afraid of this I was oh
damn they're using her power I'm so so
sorry yeah they established that she
didn't have to be like that she gets
abused it's you she's the inside she can
be controlled she becomes dismissive
about there's things about her
interactions with Andre before I was
like why weird you brush stuff under the
rug and that's why she's not weird about
the Andre thing cuz she's using him did
you ask if Marie was freaked out no I
just assume that that's what she'd want
that's on
you look for all you know she's cool
with hiding the sausage and bumping
Donuts like sometimes I hide in the
women's showers and watch girls off and
sometimes I hide in the men's and gender
is just a
construct what the dude hey maning
sh it's um that's not cool shaving
that's assault go she's super pissed at
me Sloan wait come on don't be like
that that's um sexual assault man yeah a
lot of it the most innocuous attitude
just brush that off yep now they going
to go sleep with the Llama the show's
proba cancel
genv
problematic what the hell happened to
you oh my god oh no the cycle starts
again I have no idea well no but but
um cricket was there I know I said that
we were cool I don't know if that's
actually true I mean I've been doing a
lot of thinking and wait you never said
oh how far back did they wi Chase Rufus
Rufus the psychic
guy he wiped you again it's like getting
rufi over and over again go kick rufus's
ass yeah I don't care I mean there's
always a good reason I mean from what
we've heard I think there's something
there
oh wow she's going to ReDiscover it a
weird turn of events everyone will check
in with a blonde girl yeah I forgot her
name in the heart of the moment cap cap
yeah oh my God like hypnosis oh you're
the get out get out I get it guys I get
it they know something's wrong and
they're going to keep looking and
they're going to figure it out
eventually and I'm just going to you two
are the most attractive evil women I've
ever SE seen
super villain models secret
cabal I know the hellfire club when I
see
it oh no she's not evil she's being used
to manipulated yeah very much so but
still hurt people hurt people I tried I
really tried I I knew she going to get
killed sorry sweetheart I know what I've
asked you to do is difficult she knows
how to play this like matriarch quality
mm victim but motherly all I've ever
asked is that you try use your gift for
no matter how hot it gets because you're
the only one who can keep your friends
safe no matter how evil the good doing
becomes keep doing it I could learn so
much from her dude how to be
manipulative 101 how to manipulate
people and whenn
Friends shorter book how to leverage
trauma and Influence
People proof you were there that was the
proof that's what I'm saying that's
that's what I was oh proof oh no no
proof that you were there oh sorry it's
a little EMP a little more F would have
help emphasiz the d word earlier run out
of
emphasis Sam I don't remember you no but
I do believe you I
do I mean you were right someone made me
forget you well poor guy it's not your
fault she made Luke forget me too who is
she
cruel oh my my God she made Luke I think
so oh yeah I think she's been the tool
for all for the whole time I didn't even
think it went that far back and that's
why they were together it was a setup
relationship by the principal she's been
with them mind wiping them over and over
again that is cruel never mind don't
feel too far lady that's his line just
Decades of trauma Scientology is
great oh my God even this drug which
makes you forget stuff everything is
forget toxic entities's John or whatever
they're
called his commentary was hilarious he
hated that kid he really did the Mesmer
oh is that the Haley Joel lman one am I
wrong about that oh you're right from
like season two of The Boys yeah
yeah stay the
away
okay
but he keeps does she likes intervene
when I got questions I swear to Christ I
never touched any of you what are you
and shy up to oh my God there's a stop
sign in the back warning us
stop set deside
symbolism I wiped your memory tonight
right except I couldn't have done that
because my powers only work up close and
I've been here for the last 5 hours
please tell them oh hey
on 2 CB right now but that sounds right
Dusty good reveal
joke no Emma's trying to wipe the memory
can't we found Rus it's not him oh wait
no the Kate is Kate em people's
names it's Kate please please don't why
would you say that why would you say
that
name it's not him it's Kate what that
assing crazy but it's true you sure I'm
sure okay oh W dang
what damn it oh we got a villain fight
so smart
Terminator oh my God to run with
me it wasn't him it was Kate
Kate would never do something like that
don't tell them it isn't true fess up
I'm so sorry oh oh man I've only ever
wanted to help and protect you oh no oh
this is so
sad you're all lying you're
all it back in you can't please I love
you oh getting all that back damn this
is like some Legion stuff never seen
Legion but it looks like the legion
trailer this seems like
Legion understand I
didn't oh man Redemption Arc you got to
redeem yourself you can fill their back
in
too give a little bop bop gonna bleed
from the eyes you I Put A Spell On You
song play oh man dang she's like Hue
mine season one Huey betraying them
right guys I'm just drawing parallels
and references to other things that
people have seen I got to do that stop
sign to a breakdown on you yep that's
true all right guys well all right if
you're listening to this on Apple and
Spotify please go ahead rate this video
and now before we talk about this
episode which really really did enjoy I
wanted to First say Coy you're looking
good in that shirt right there like it's
a nice good like it's good fabric it's
good fit it's good you know you got and
it's a little reject Nation little real
re at this and I'm a big movie theater
person I like purchasing tickets and
here we are sharing the exhibition
industry that is movies so much at the
time when I get goosebumps I sometimes
get nipple chills my goodness and I can
get all this stuff at www. reation
shop.com thank you guys so much who have
been watching this Channel and then also
been supporting us in one of the best
ways possible by getting yourself some
awesome tees over there we got awesome
te's such as our child protection
services shirt with Pedro Pascal from
Last of Us carrying baby grou we also
got this recently launched Ahsoka snip
snip lightsaber scissors shirt we got
this who influences the influencers
Watchman inspired one the other day I
cooked up a possible boys inspired tea I
want to see if I can develop it before
the end of the finale so that way it's
relevant but I think people will like it
if I can get it done in time but yeah we
got a whole bunch of other shirts as
well uh seriously whenever one of these
is bought by bought whenever one of
these is bought I I feel very very proud
because this is one that we are
creatively involved with ourselves it's
not just something that is just thrown
out there and like hey let's plug it now
this is a a true development of reject
Nation so thank you guys it's one of the
best ways to represent yourself as a
citizen of this reject Nation but yeah
let's talk about this episode yeah I did
I definitely um uh we definitely shot
this uh shirt thing afterwards CU I
forgot to mention
it see if there's a GRE did was he C us
there's going to be a
transition
now I got explain this ending Greg
explain this well ending explained is
um you know um black guy and black girl
they had a falling out because uh found
out she's been wiping everyone's memory
oh I see I see and he explained right
there explain
17 explain can't tell you Emma Emma's
the bad girl Emma's calling you're like
not Emma Emma's doing
great I forget people's names Em's the
one we should trust yes Emma good M even
right now
Andre no no you paused you're like Kate
M we just like IMDb up over here forget
people's names second screen IMDb so my
okay that was a really great episode all
right so all right hey I got one Theory
right I mean it's a pretty obvious one
the wipe at the end of last week yeah
hey it did disorient you eventually have
to conclude that right I feel like
everyone probably concluded that yeah
yeah
um well my qu I thought that was really
well I mean first off I just thought
that was a really great episode um and
it was it was really uh this was
probably the most like pulsating one I
would say oh I like how tight it was
there was Rhythm it was tense and it was
like that this the most edgier seat kind
of experience with it like you could
feel the ramp up I feel like while this
is a great week toe show it's also a
great bin show simultaneously because
you could just feel like everything
escalating in and the frustration you
feel as an audience member of like no
remember crap this is happening yeah I I
love the that pull that it's doing and
the villain I did not at all see that I
haven't even heard that theory go out
there I that was actually a fresh
villain
that
Kate Kate throw out a white woman name
and there it is one about to say they
should really make their names different
and they could not be they are very
different Nam Emma and K they're very
different names um the uh that Kate is
the villain is is a great reveal but
she's not a villain though that's the
thing is it's very comp you could sense
that there could be a Redemption for her
actions you know like there's
consequences to what she's done but I
don't think as a character I would
categorize her as villainy you know
because it's so obvious that she's been
used and abused and manipulated and they
even talk about some tragic backstory
stuff and certain experiences that she's
had to indicate that she is someone you
can pray
upon uh which just makes it that much
more horrifying what she's going through
and yeah so like I I don't buy any
stretch hate her like I hate the actions
I condemn the actions but I don't hate
her you know makes it easier when
someone's attractive to freig that's why
that's why hot therapist like I hate her
I mean I can't
fudge her sensitive when you are
attractive it's just the way it Go
science and when attract
people is it's brain chemistry science
and when two Attractive people team up
for nefarious Deeds you know it just
becomes that much more difficult to
separate the attractive how make friends
and alien people cast people on
television left and right right and left
otherwise villains can be
blamed and frankly there's no Nuance
there not at all make them hot make them
hot black and white every cast
director's got that written in the back
of the head shot make them
hot well there's the answer
um okay my question my question that I
have is
she okay first off D explosion we'll
call it yep I don't think it happened
doesn't seem like it happened because
well he's moving pretty well you think
you would be like hospitalized and be
really upset
about would be like you did this to me
singing like a unic too like you don't
just get up from that so yeah unless it
grows back and we just don't know he
else I can also turn I reg yeah so okay
that didn't that didn't happen and he
plants that memory or she plants that I
assume she planted that I think it's all
Kate I think Kate planted the memory of
that conversation okay so she plants
that now what happens in a moment when
he's face to face with Rufus
Andre and then suddenly he's at the fast
suit place that was that was Rufus Ru
Rufus is psychic so Rufus did I think
Rufus was like why are you attacking me
wipe I'm escaping yeah that's that's the
vibe I get self-defense mind that's so
Kate's not doing separate events I
thought that the because he seemed to
okay yeah because he seemed he he was
yeah he was like oh like he was he
was aware yeah he didn't get planted he
just had time missing and then realized
when he was awake that he was just with
Rufus see I'm yeah but now I'm very kind
of I'm I'm questioning the the D
explosion scene then because that does
start with a very close proximity
encounter with Rufus that then
immediately cuts to that and is in line
with other things he's done as per
Kate's admission but also in conjunction
no to support your point that is the
start too of of um Jordan and
Marie actually uh that was the moment
when I was like oh they're going to
sleep together yeah you know but that
could be a Kate plan maybe maybe maybe
Kate literally orated the red hering of
Rufus well yeah I'm saying I'm saying
Kate orchestrated Rufus and that whole
explosion was a planted memory she can
do all that I don't know she can like
completely add memory like like create
an entire narrative I mean I guess you
could if you have the power of
suggestion you could just push it to
people that yeah you you don't remember
any of these events this is what you
remember and now that's just the whereas
Rufus is wiping she's adding yeah yeah
no she also wipes well yeah but I'm
saying she's able to replace whereas
Rufus is just it seems like there's just
gaps in time okay cuz like Kate was
saying she woke up if that story was
true which I would I would assume it is
I don't think Kate was lying I think
that's part of her experience was that
horrible situation she was in but she
didn't remember it whereas they remember
things that happened when it's Kate's
doing seemingly right yes see what I'm
saying so it's implant she talked about
she talked about her experience with
Rufus yes yes yes okay that's true so
maybe maybe Kate you know cause an
emotion a lack thereof or a plant
whereas he is just
like all right all right I'll roll with
it all right it's all good man I mean I
like this episode I really love the
chemistry of well the salonic chemistry
really came to play here because that
there was an instinctive like I like
this person I really liked how they
utilized like I just she just had this
feeling about him and that was rewarded
and I like that his Instinct wasn't like
betrayal it was I've survived them doing
this to me to to let me help you I
really liked that they their arcs feel
Fuller for this episode like Emma feels
like more of a fully formed character
and then Sam also like we're getting to
know him better and their chemistry is
feeding both of them really well yeah
speaking of feeding I'm glad that Emma
is getting the respect and recognition
from feeding herself Y and seeing the
opposite effect like she's becoming more
full of life it's like very metaphorical
that the way they I think what this this
show has done really well is drawing the
metaphoric
emotional psychological Journeys via
their powers in conjunction yeah this
ruy episode was dark like just the idea
of losing time and like being assaulted
and all those things that are I mean it
was a very violently sexually charged
episode but about things that are like
traumatic and I think they utilize that
well as like a guys it's not your fault
like you said victim blaming like there
was a moment where she like blamed
herself and it's it's looking at like
the villain here yeah but I don't think
that guy could run with Ed de so I I
think
he's we really got to get to the bottom
why make you more aam that's true that's
true yeah think of a Kendall but with
that injury like that you would probably
need time to heal mhm seemed like that
was like two days ago well they were
asleep for three or four maybe six days
ago still maybe they have someone whose
superpowers is to fix these things like
my hero Academia somebody just kisses it
and then it's you know fixed or
something that's another episode don't
worry they'll show it I like this
episode quite a bit as well and I think
that with you know we live in a time
where now like the run times of episodes
are no longer uniformed unless you're on
like Network TV and so sometimes that
can lead to like oh here's a short
episode and it feels that way whereas
this one still felt like it was pce the
right way it was proportionate the right
way and I did appreciate that you have
all these different sides of the mystery
kind of pulling out and pushing in and
you've got people's like Minds getting
wiped and they didn't use that to spin
their wheels or to like save these
conflicts for later which I thought was
a nice thing it's like they still no
matter how many Minds got wiped people
are still kind kind of realizing
something's up chasing that thread or
pulling that thread and so you have
these moments where you do get these you
know it's like you have the thing with
um uh Marie and Jordan where it's like
oh okay so here we go we're going to
have some kind of conflict it's G to
drive a wedge between their relationship
but then they actually confront that
they each have scenes with other people
to kind of get their own conf uh you
know get some guidance and then they
come back and they actually have a talk
with each other and then that kind of
ties back into the plot and then
everybody trying to remember what's
going on in the woods and everything and
and The Trackers and stuff like that
like again I'm used to shows being like
okay so now we're going to wipe
someone's mind or we're going to you
know have this reveal and then we're
going to you know Stave off developments
for a little while but yeah this this I
thought was nicely realistically messy
under those circumstances this worked
for me in all the ways that the Mind
wipe didn't work for me when it was a
mystery remember the end of the episode
we're all like that's kind of just like
like disappointing like it just didn't
feel like it was cooked this felt cooked
and I really liked I agree with the
runtime I really like that the the
episode got to have this frenetic Pace
as opposed to feeling like it was just
shortened or them pacing it to hit that
50s something minute like this I I like
uh streaming allowing some episodes are
like an hour and 10 and something can be
like 37 or whatever it was yeah man this
is a great episode I really enjoy I'm
back uh yeah I didn't really leave for a
second I thought Koy was out the window
guys I'm done with
ch no no it just it dipped a little bit
and now it's back to where it started
for me yeah I know I thought this was
one of their best ones uh so far I think
what's interesting about this world of
gen V specifically is that the world and
its purpose for serving in the boy
Universe
becomes more fleshed out the more we
experience this show because like we're
calling it gen
V I like the title a lot because it's
the I what I imagine the purpose of it
when I think about it is that this is
the first set of people at this school
who are going here of kids who know that
their powers were given to them via
science experiment from their parents
whereas before it was like God blessed
me with these Powers you know so I think
calling it gen V is is pretty smart and
this is allowing them the opportunity to
take control and make the choices of
what they can do with their powers so
weirdly with the B
I wouldn't call that a superhero show
it's a show about people with
superpowers under the guys of
superheroism but they're the villains of
that show yeah and then here it's like
oh we actually have a superhero show now
yeah depending on how this all goes but
but I'm under the impression that oh we
actually have superheroes now this is
the first time in the boys universe that
you know you got characters like
Starlight who I would and you got people
who who do good deeds and who are do
want to be super actual superheroes but
this is like our protagonists here for
the most part seem like they're good
people they want to make the right
choice even with someone like Rufus who
is a terrible human being he they do not
kill him at the end of the day it's not
the right call to kill this person uh
they still make the call to not
sacrifice a person's life these guys are
actual superheroes and they are taking
control of that I'm really hoping that
like in the comic there's a lot of
episodes issues that feel like episodes
where there's a payoff in one and then
like later in the next Arc you meet that
character again in a new place in their
life I would love if one of these
characters becomes the seven at the end
of this that beol like the finale we
find out who number one at the school is
and the number one gets promoted to the
boys and they're in the boys season four
because I mean it's all one Universe
it'd be great if because I really enjoy
the product placement of the Amazon vot
situation in both shows but I've really
been lik linked to homelander Burger and
stuff I would love if we see whoever it
is uh whether it's Marie or maybe Andre
whoever they get brought into the world
of the boys and then we already loved
them enough that we get to see the world
of the boys that we love meeting this
character that we spent this whole
season with and go like oh how is that
conflict because then you've earned what
I wanted Marvel to do with their TV
which is pay off a long run origin with
a movie payoff and then you feel like
you've really gotten to experience An
Origin story this could do that first
yeah and there's something interesting
about that Prospect too because I I
think your point is is good about the
like the title is great because a I mean
yeah it is the literal descriptor of
everybody growing up under this new kind
of age of knowledge and superheroism and
and everything in between but also does
hearken to jenzi and that is you know
the sort of most uh actively sort of
Awakened generation in terms of like
challenging you know the status quo and
things like that and certainly these
characters are motivated to you know
awaken to and challenge you know the
systems that are being thrust upon them
as normal and natural by everyone above
them in control and so you know bringing
one of these characters into a world
like the boys then subsequently I think
does make for an interesting you know a
slightly different entry way to have
that challenge to the status quo happen
on that stage and that scale in a way
that yeah you can feel like you really
grew with and you understand the
perspective of and that you know could
you know change that show a little bit
and also I don't know I I feel like
these shows could if everything goes
well kind of feed each other and affect
each other and kind of challenge each
other to get better and sharper and all
yeah like a season 4 to lead into a genv
season 2 and then like I mean I want two
boys a year and and have them be
different shows like they are yeah
that'd be great well guys what did you
think about this episode what are your
theories for episode six leave them down
in the comments below do you think Kate
will be redeemed do you forgive bad
people if they are attractive leave it
down in the comments below does Rufus
still have a wiener
subscribe leave a
[Music]
like